anh alo chào bạn
anh Đợi mình tí
thể Sau một hồi nó biến hình rối và nhau
được như này phải chờ
mấy cái chỗ cơ bản cơ bản thôi và tôi
cảm thấy là nếu mà cứ dậy mấy cái
thì các bạn này mà không nói gì đó mới
nó hơi bị nhàm chán Nhưng mà nếu mà
cô dạy cải lương cao quá ví dụ Giả sử
hôm trước dậy và nâng cao quá thì à
xe hơi kén người nghe một tí các bạn về
cơ bản các bạn cũng mới tôi mới dậy vừa
lao ra mà nâng cao quái các bạn sẽ có
thể bị thoáng
em heo dạy cơ bản quá hiểu xem thêm sửa
xóa Thì nó nhằm thì gần như bà ngạo như
bảng nào
ta Nó không phải là kiểu dạng thêm sửa
xóa đơn thuần khiến này mình sẽ thử phân
tích trước mày Tao sẽ dạy mày ông ấy
cách phân tích trước vấn đề gì đó chứ
khi bắt đầu làm Bởi vì hôm trước thì tôi
cũng bảo là cuối buổi tôi sẽ chỉn quên
mất đấy là của cuối buổi tôi sẽ chị mấy
ông là mình trước khi làm một cái gì đó
mà mình sẽ phân tích chán chê đã bắt tay
vào làm à
Hồ Ngọc Hà Đợi tí nữa chị
anh tí nhé
ở tập hát
vợ chẳng biết rằng tôi đang như nào luôn
à
ờ ờ
Ừ thì hôm trước tôi bảo là tôi sẽ định
làm phân tích của khối buổi mình bản
chất là mình sẽ vẽ cái phom trước mình
thường vẽ về phone trước để mình hình
dung ra à Cái tính năng này bản chất nó
là cần phải làm gì không ạ
ờ ờ tôi xem lại một tí về hôm trước mình
đã phân tích tính năng nhé sau đó Thì
bây giờ mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ bắt tay vào làm tính năng gì
Ê mày đi à
ạ Bây giờ mình đang làm ở bên quản trị
viên không ạ quản lý hôm trước làm quản
lý người dùng cứ gọi là quản lý được rồi
đi Thì bây giờ mình sẽ là quản lý
file thương da là quản lý file phải sau
mình sẽ phải quản lý bài đăng trước thì
sẽ về
gần nhà hoặc là hoặc là mình sẽ làm ở
bên nhà Tuyển dụng trước đi đâu được
Chính ăn pin cũng thể đang được bày
chính xác Thế chị nhắn Min có thể làm
được bài hộ cho nhà Tuyển dụng với tôi
giờ đang có 1
ô mai có thưởng thức tôi sẽ thì đăng mà
Thì sẽ làm nha Vợ tôi hôm nay tôi sẽ
hướng dẫn các bạn làm đăng bài luôn cái
đã phải sửa lại CRD đấy là đăng bài đăng
hay gió quản lý 3 Đăng đúng không ạ Đấy
thì cái quản lý bài đăng này tôi cần
hình dung cái cái cái giao diện mà sẽ
chồng như nào tôi luôn yêu cầu sinh viên
mình phải làm ra diện với cái quả này
Ê mày không hiểu gì đâu không ạ Mình sẽ
hôm trước là tôi nhiều tôi vẽ và cái
chết Ma vẽ bằng cái gì đó à
gì đó để mình dễ hình dung ấy thì ông là
kiểu nó như nào như nào
Ừ cái trang Tôi nhớ là cái thang này vẽ
vẽ kiểu dạng giao diện có thử được
Ừ nhưng mà tôi hôm trước tôi dùng thằng
ngày chưa quen lo lắm kiểu như này từng
bước từng bước như thế này
quen thằng này lắm nhưng thì nha Hơi khó
dùng
ờ ờ
Cho xem ảnh để tôi xem một tí nhá
chứ không phải mình cứ thẳng lên hẳn
dro.io cho dễ vẽ đi
quản lý bà đang đúng không là post ở
I bought sau đó thì đây là Iraq trước đi
thì mình sẽ có đây là tê Giả sử d giao
diện trang web của mình này đúng ạ Mình
sẽ ở đây có
anh kể cái Menu bỏ qua nha nên ngu thì
mình vẫn đương nhiên chắc hẳn có cái
Menu rồi ông ạ
thì
mình chắc chắn là có cái men ngủ đây rồi
không ạ Mình mình còn menu với này rồi
Mọi thứ cái này tôi quan tâm người anh
giữ thôi cái giữa thì đầu tiên là mình
cần hả Mình đưa làm quản lý bài đăng thì
cần Hiển thị các xay khô rồi Các giữ thứ
thông tin của ngoạn ở
không ạ
ở công ty bà đang thì nó sẽ gồm cái gì
chạm nó sẽ gồm những cái gì Tôi nhớ nó
có cái bàn này
Ừ cái bồ này này đúng rồi à chị sẽ có
bảo này
Vì Sao Thế
bãi chúng tôi hoa mới không ạ Ừ
em lấy ảnh này rồi nhỉ Mình sẽ có bảng
đây là
Ừ
để xem
và đương nhiên có cái nút thêm mà nó
trên này đúng không Mình còn nút duyệt
ừ ừ tôi đang cân nhắc người vụ tạo cái
bảng cho đẹp đẹp một tí Nếu này hơi xấu
quá
ở khó vậy
ông xã mình nuôi vuốt ra để ngồi làm cái
đó ngay Đợi tí Đợi tí nhé Em phải có cái
bảng tử tế nhỉ
Ê mày có về không lẽ chuyên mạnh ở đây
đây đây đây à
có ai phải buồn nó thấy buồn
Ừ ok
Âm Nhạc
Ừ anh
Anh thường là mình hướng đến thì sẽ là
kiểu dạng số thứ tự rồi đúng không tiếp
theo là
a tiếp theo sẽ là ở Thái Tổ
Ừ
đợi xem xem lại cài đặt ai đã
ở góc Thái thổ Đông ạ ạ
Ừ cái việc này đôi khi ở ngựa các bạn
nghĩ là kiểu mình thà ngồi Cốt nó còn
nhanh hơn nhưng mà đôi khi mình sẽ phải
làm cái này trước Ừ vợ tôi hướng dẫn méo
nhà phân tích trước mà mày ông sẽ phải
làm phân tích sau đó thì còn đưa cái bản
phân tích để cho người khác thì người
khác bắt tay vào cốt ở chung là chúng ta
sẽ cùng nhau thảo luận về cái này để
phân tích ra các yếu thứ chứ không phải
là kiểu
a cho dạ cứ cắm đầu vào à ở kiểu cầm đâu
và làm thì à
nó không chuyên nghiệp lắm Bọn mình mình
trưởng thành rồi mình không làm thế
cả ngày cho thai Hồ
info các tướng thứ để mà lo ví dụ là
Ừ cái này là
Ừ cái này đều chung Nó là kiểu là
Em in force là cái này location location
à
một cái ô nữa về này cơ
á hậu Nga
bộ remote
bộ remote để kiểu in nó lấy mình để kiểu
là để nghĩa là gì nhé
Vì sao mày để kiểu in đâu Chở mày
i m các bạn không có comment đấy chấm
biết cái remote này để Tại sao để nhà
luôn à
thế này
em có cho phép vmode này không
anh như thế remote Apple thì nó gần hơn
remote Apple nghĩa là cho phép remote nó
dễ hơn vì mỗi bộ
a tiếp theo là ít part time
I spent
à à
cái kia đi qua mình qua mình bỏ qua tại
sao Vì thấy cả tôi không quan tâm một
cái điều này ở bên emminh không cần quan
tâm đến nay
started And I
chị sẽ là
à À jandi không
à à
expire hai nơi trú ẩn tại Iceland
number application status
là người dùng không cập nhật thường
xuyên ở trên này kiểu đã có bao nhiêu
người đã đăng ký và mình không nhập cái
điều đấy Ở đây mình cũng khó mà biết
được là cái chóp này lượng người đăng ký
đã đủ chưa hay còn thiếu bao nhiêu người
thế là tôi
lên đây cho có thôi
Ừ chứ không có tác dụng gì lắm Sẽ có
Chào tất
cho ex finish để để pim pim Pino
khi xu
anh không cần và thêm một cột nữa cột
Quét tất
cho xem
Anh không biết là làm đây là lao để
I like that
ở
lại đại khái mình sẽ gần này cột
ạ Bây giờ mày không thấy cái giao diện
này trông có vẻ hơi nhằm sẵn Tôi tôi
đang chưa hình dung là nên vẽ bằng cái
gì
Ê mấy ông có thể đề xuất tôi cải trang
để vẽ giao diện khác thay vì cái Trang
do ở trăng dôi Tôi nghĩ không chuyên thì
lẽ ra diện nhưng mà mình sẽ vẽ trước
giao diện Xong rồi dạt sự mình sẽ vẽ dần
dần mấy cái kiểu khốn nút ở đây như nào
Vân cái form mình nên Trông như nào Vân
để mà mình hình dung ra cốt để không
hiểu gì tôi không còn bây giờ tôi chỉ
đang đề mua thôi Cái này thì có thể nó
mấy ông thấy quá cơ bản chả cần này vẽ
cũng được không sao cả nếu mà có nhiều
cái bài toán nó giúp ta ví dụ Giả sử là
tiền hình điển hình là cái tính năng nha
những tính năng của ở bên ứng viên này
tìm kiếm công việc ạ thì cái giao diện
nó phải trông như thế nào thì lúc này
bắt buộc mày không phải vẽ ra là hồi hồi
mà tôi dậy ở trên trưởng ấy thì tôi
thường ấy Phát
Ừ hôm đấy tôi bảo tất cả sinh viên à
không không cốc hôm đấy mà gần như là sẽ
chị có dùng máy tính để mà lên tất cả
các trang mà kiểu cùng cùng cái kiểu
cùng làm cái trang web ví dụ là đây
trang web với tuyển dụng rồi lại lên để
tham khảo để giao diện nó rồi mình sẽ
phải tự vẽ cái giao diện của riêng mình
tôi phát cho sinh viên giấy A4 rồi sinh
viên sẽ dùng bút để vẽ luôn không không
dùng cái trang gì cả đôi khi là mấy ông
dùng bút đấy nếu không sẽ này ý tưởng
hơn mấy ông hình Do cái thì mày ông nên
dùng bút để mà ngồi kiểu phác thảo lại ý
tưởng phát Hảo lại cái giao diện của cha
người như thế nào từ mấy cái xanh rất là
đơn giản thì indec như này cũng vẽ này
trang kiểu xem thêm sữa xóa đầy đủ tất
cả vẫn phải vẽ hết tất cả để mở hình
dung được nghĩa là có tí sẽ vẽ gỗ thực
chất là bấm vào nút này bạn sẽ là nó sẽ
hiển thị form Trong như nào có nút nào
đầu tiên có cái gì cần điền đầu tiên và
văn phải liều kế hết sao tất cả đời
người bắt đầu một cốt mày ông hình dong
o để vẽ hết tất cả cái đã
Ừ Ok bây giờ cái gì à
Ừ đợi xử lý con chó à
Bây giờ sang bên đầu tiên là mình sẽ
tên là mình sẽ kiểu có
đã có trên menu đúng ạ Mình sẽ có trên
menu là kiểu bài đăng không ạ Rồi mẹ
chàng tôi đây đây mình sẽ có bài đăng ở
chuyện tất cả bài đăng nhập
khi tôi bỏ qua vì cái biểu tượng nhé với
ông về sau có thể sửa cái biểu tượng của
tôi phát và về sau mình tự chỉnh nhanh
sau mình mất tầm nửa tiếng rồi mọc tất
cả biểu tượng sao à
làm ăn lên cho anh The men is gì này anh
sẽ quản lý bài đăng này quản lý cái gì
đó Ở đây
anh ở đây sẽ là một
trong như này
là
thế mạnh cho chồng đỡ khó chửi đã Chả
ảnh hưởng gì lắm đâu à
đi xóa lại đi này
ở đây mình sẽ tạo cost controller đúng
không ạ à
thỉnh thoảng biết đâu đấy Có vấn đề gì
đó
cho phép mỗi rồi này
ạ
sau đó thì à
á ha này
controller posts
ở lại
kỹ thuật lái xe at first trailer
à à
mình sẽ có mất tích phẳng truyền lại
Index II
hot
girl à ở đây Ừ hình như vừa rồi nó tạo
hơi sai nó phải nằm Bến admin mới đúng
có lẽ amin Tôi bị nhầm đấy tôi có một
cách nhanh để mấy ông sửa các đoạn này
như thế này mấy ông có thể ở Mở bên áp
là TP này trả lời đúng không Mày không
có thể Vứt cái này với Song Ngư lại sau
đó thì resort poster như này
ừ ừ
ở đó thì ông sẽ thấy là newspace nào đã
Lập tức thay đổi và nó thay đổi luôn ở
toàn bộ chỗ nào nhưng từng nhắc thì nó
Nếu thấy ngon không ra ngon không ạ Đấy
nó làm được điều này tôi không biết được
à thằng à vé code của mấy ông có làm
được không
em vẫn sẽ phải copy rồi đoạn này
Tôi đã tạo một ngày tôi thưởng ngay tại
một cái là test em solo sau đó đi cốt để
mà chuyên test là cả sẽ Cậu dễ copy copy
cả tôi tạo luôn cho Mấy ông
xe tải tại một tôi copy này nha
Ừ tối gà controller này để tạo một file
file test container chuyên đề chuyên
that I
thế này sau đó đi nespace có bao nhiêu
không phải như này rồi
ở
đây sẽ Attach container đối ngoại à
này
Ừ cái tắt container này ngoài Nghĩa vụ
là tiểu
thì nó sẽ có những cái chung chung như
này cho mình dậy copy
copy từ file này sao phải kia dễ mình
sửa lại tên file thôi tên kontro rồi mà
vì sao mình sẽ làm phải thứ nữa là tôi
rất thích nhưng mà tạm một cái
controller kiểu giống như một cân cho
lâu chung với một phòng chung ấy lại dây
cáp
ờ ờ
controller tôi nghĩa lại này chung được
mỗi view này nó thay đổi này
chú bộ đội tôi một tí
ừ ừ
chị sẽ tạo contact ở bên này được à
3:00
vẫn phải khai báo lại rồi
Ừ
nó bên mình chỉ cần đổi lại cái này hả
Út Night
ở đó
anh nghe được à
a tiếp theo là đây mình sẽ
Tata bằng brigitte
sơ đồ
lễ hội tép ngay Lấy toàn bộ tất cả bài
đăng về này sò Return về video này
amin.no
[âm nhạc]
ở một ở như này hay là mình hông sử dụng
mà đã Suite để mà
Xin chào dữ liệu về nhập khẩu api
à Tôi nghĩ ở đoạn này tôi nên làm à
ở giai đoạn này
các bạn này tôi sẽ làm api để mà trả dữ
liệu về
Ê bà trộn cũng sẽ cho bé không biết về à
ATM luôn
Ừ để xem Đợi tôi một tí nhé
ăn mì bản chất đây là tất cả các bài
đăng mà Ok được thôi đoạn này tôi sẽ làm
api trong những xem nhé
Xóa lại đến
mình sẽ có là
đầu tiên nằm trong admin này tạo một thư
mục
ý là posts ngày đi
jac.pro
đ.tp đúng không ạ
thôi tôi chưa khỏi có viết đâu ạ
à Thế bây giờ tôi chưa test lại Mai tôi
định tái lại may ra Tối định là tôi
thường chứ ca tôi ở Định ở chung nhà tôi
ở trong nhà suốt mà thực ra tôi không
quan trọng việc và phải test như kiểu
các thứ trừ khi cần phải ra ngoài nhưng
mà mai á ông bạn tôi định qua nhà chơi
ngoài việc là ông đấy từ trong Nam ông
mới bay ra đây để mà
để mà có việc tranh thủ qua chơi thì cái
thứ hai đó là ông mình sẽ qua để mà chỉ
tôi cách dạy tôi học guitar để tán gái
Ông dặn thầy dễ ngủ cực Đúng rồi tôi
biết giọng tôi nó hơi đều đều đều tí khi
mà nó dạy thôi cái đoạn này thì ra khó
mà tỏ khó mà dậy cuốn được cái đoạn này
nó
anh không biết như thế nào Ôi Mọi khi
thì có lúc thì tôi sẽ có ví dụ gì hay
hay được đoạn này tôi không biết ví dụ
thế nào hay nữa chứ
guitar rồi mà tán gái
ở đây
em copy này
copy này à
à à
anh ở đây mình sẽ có ít cá à
a table
Thực ra thì tôi vẫn không định là
Ừ tôi không định là mình sẽ dùng đã ta
thấy bấm trưởng này lắm
ở đây tớ xem à
em bata thấy bổ ở đây ạ
Ê tao thấy bồ đấy thì
thì mình sẽ phải con có dữ liệu
thuần phần à
thứ thôi cho mày đó nha em nhé á
quên quên quên
Ê mày có là
Đã trót say thôi à
an apple i
a
remote Apple
Ừ mai mốt đi remote table
a remote thay bộ à
Ừ đúng nhỉ cái mốt thấy bổ như lại có
thể di chuyển được gì cả
ạ
ờ ờ
à à
áo len
a merry
tiếp their Friends
xem nhé
à à
anh ta
bí quyết
ở đất ở
đấy là bên admin thôi bên A Bên khách
hàng thì tôi về sau tôi hướng dẫn lừa
anh cả anh và việc được
lỗi
khi sex
Em bảo nó sẽ như thế này
à nhờ đây đây đây mới là
hôm nay mình sẽ có t-body ở trong ngày
không ạ sau đó mình sẽ vứt dữ liệu ở
trong này thì sẽ có phút CS ở đây và đây
mình sẽ gọi em út này
vào đây sẽ vip của mình Mình sẽ có
cho tôi bảo rồi tôi có thích gõ gg bằng
cybertech xin phép gõ bằng tay ra nhé
vì
vậy nó đi suốt ngon hơn không ạ Hay đề
xuất của wap
sẽ còn dai đi Ở đây này cho con mình ra
đi Này mình bản chất là khi mà cha được
lót xong thì mình sẽ load dữ liệu ra để
mở kiểu thì chị ra không ạ Ở đây có ai
sắc này
api shop
ở trong Trưởng trong trường hợp này tôi
sẽ
Ừ tôi có thể để nó là như thế này về bản
chất là tôi muốn có file api riêng thì
nó sẽ rất là trong cái cái này đây này
có một cái chỗ riêng là chỗ api này tôi
sẽ tống vào trong này cơ đấy có sẽ là
api sau đó thì off chọn này như thế Tôi
muốn như thế này một như thế này là
đương nhiên method sẽ bé cho két thôi bỏ
qua trả về sẽ rất là lo trả lời dặn sinh
thôi Ờ
ở đây tôi sẽ tống vào trong này này
em lấy đỡ Sửa tin nhắn tới sửa tí đây
mình sẽ có
như thế thôi
motor ghét tốt nhà chẳng
Ừ chắc là mình sẽ gọi đến phốt
controller
3000 mình cũng sẽ đúng mình vẫn sẽ gọi
đến 3 controller nhưng mà là
xe đạp trên Zalo này chúng là thành phố
container từ admin
nói như thế này cơ
cô gái gợi ý là chả biết thế nào mà lần
luôn à
Ok nghe này Tại sao tự nhiên do để tạo
ra cái này thằng ngày để mà mình sẽ dùng
chung cho thằng bên admin này nên hát
pro đấy và bên
amply cân nghĩa là thằng người ứng tuyển
đấy Cái cái api đó sẽ trả về dữ liệu
đương nhiên nó sẽ khác 1 tí nhưng về
chung thì nó sẽ chuyên để mà trả với dữ
liệu đấy đấy tác dụng của Fa nó sẽ như
thế
ở lại nó sẽ là trái với dữ liệu nhé á
À mà quên copy ở bên A test controller ở
nhà
em ở bên anh
Ừ cái này không Bên này là ý kia lên bản
chất là tôi sẽ không có một cái view gì
đấy Cả
Em có thấy bồ luôn
ông truyền lại yeah cái này bản chất là
mình sẽ
giúp là post ở đây
à à
ra sau đó mình sẽ tristan thẳng cái này
hàng ngày luôn cũng được ai
nhà mình có khi Huy tôm thẳng luôn hả
Được
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
ở đâu gọi điện X2 thằng này
à Tôi nhớ hôm trước mà tôi làm cái vụ
này không phải đăng fail mình sắp xít ở
đây thì chuẩn hơn còn sắp xít với ai
em restore như thế nào
chả vậy Cái gì là nếu mà à
e-hero chạm với cái gì nay
gì lên
em à Có mình sẽ có chuyện lên mình sẽ
truyền à Cái keyness của mình kiểu đang
ở trang thứ bao nhiêu là Trang thử bao
nhiêu
Tí là tôi sẽ tách thử cái vụ gọi đến api
post này cho mày không Xe này tôi tôi sẽ
gọi đến cái đường link
gì tôi copy đây này gọi đến đường Minh
là api 2/3 tốt như này Ừ thì nó sẽ cần
trả về cho tôi lại mày không khéo sẽ trả
về cho tôi cài danh sách này nhưng nếu
không để ý kĩ Ừ nó trả về tôi hơi nhiều
thông tin có phép tết như này ngay các
thứ thứ thì thôi cả Tôi muốn làm đơn
giản là kéo chỉ quan tâm bây giờ là có
có
có chăng tiếp theo hay không hả Thế hay
gì đó làm việc đơn giản hơn thì tôi sẽ
có khái niệm là simple
khi xuat ngày đó tôi dạng rất là đơn
giản
Ừ vậy thì xóa này đấy ạ ạ
à à
do đó nó có phước tết như này nhưng nó
chỉ quan tâm mình việc à Có chanh tiếp
theo hay không đã bắt đầu từ đâu kết
thúc là xanh như thế nào
chú ý thông tin thôi đấy ở đây để so
sánh với ông xem nhé á
A specialist tại đúng không
ừ ừ
này em ấy ông ứng vào này
Ừ chiều này không sao kiểu này không sao
thật ở xem
cho nó xịn hẳn nhé Để
Ừ ừ quên mất là cái này cần phải đổ ra
giao diện cho mình nữa Ừ thôi cứ để hẳn
ngay đi
tôi gọi đến cái api vừa rồi sẽ lấy được
các dữ liệu mình đang truyền lên mình cứ
tạm để đã
về bản chất là nó sẽ trả về mình dữ liệu
sau đó đi tôi sẽ cân đầu ở trong này cái
dữ liệu đấy thì mình sẽ còn là
tôi đặt tên ở đây thường là tôi sẽ ID
giờ đây nó sẽ là tê bồ nhà gì đó Thấy
bốt nha trở lại thấy bồ data đi ngay
Ở
đây có là bị sẽ đổ toàn bộ vào cái bồ
data này
này thì mấy ông nghĩ là tôi có thể làm
tao thấy bồ đoạn này được cho nhanh
nhưng mà tôi đang muốn chỉ với ông phần
da Speed bị nào ạ
anh hiểu rằng là khi mình nhảy sáng
trang khác mình không có tìm kiếm của
đạp ra đây bồ hiểu
bạn này bản chất là mình trả về dữ liệu
nó sẽ trả về trong việc data này có
nhưng mà tôi nhớ là tôi từng tạm vậy
thôi chưa thích các tổ chức fake cái à Ừ
tôi chưa làm cái sách Kể lại bài đăng
lên thì nha Đang không có dữ liệu gì trả
về cả xem nhé đoạn này mình sẽ trả về dữ
liệu mình sẽ đợi cho sách dữ liệu của
cái này đã
em chẳng biết là nên khách hay à làm
thật hẳn luôn nữa
em có khi là tôi thêm tôi dậy đà Hôm nay
tôi sẽ dạy thêm mà Ừ tôi dậy người ông
thêm trước đi
Tôi có một cái ở đây một cái khát hết
đâu này
à à
router
I love family chị sẽ
để đến Naruto là amin
post-grad thế mới thấy sẽ là flash này
Ừ Vậy tí Đợi tí nhé
chi tiết hàng ngày
a Chất hàng ngày nó phải là
hỗ trợ thông tí mình sẽ sửa lại bên A có
phải đô router Switch hình có đây rồi
Nhưng mình chỉ còn nên với nó nên ở đây
là thời kỳ 2
gì chấm như này
xe ô tô Ok Ok you the way I
đánh đất sẽ là phốt chậm như thế này
của tôi là
I bought chấm maknoon để xem nha rốt là
bản chất là mình sẽ lấy về
qua Inax được sẽ như anh thôi sẽ chạy
thôi
Cho tôi nghe được
bài hát nick tôi bé
anh alo alo nick bé mix bé
Ừ ok Bây giờ cháu nói to hơn rồi đúng
không ạ
đ.d bấm mà Thì sẽ là thêm thì mày đang
đúng không ạ ạ
ngoài đĩa thêm bài đăng thì đương nhiên
là nó sẽ nằm ở bên admin
áo
len mình sẽ tạo một cái pho mới thêm
led đ.tp này chả lo tôi đang nói châm
đấy chứ chứ không Tôi không nghĩ là nó
bé đó à
anh ở đây copy cái giao diện bên này cho
nhanh nhé
anh nghe tạm không có ra Swift đi mình
sẽ có đây là
anh ở đây mình sẽ có cáp body ở đây mình
sẽ có một cái phom ạ Còn Đây lát
vi phạm
e-zone à Hồi rô là hình theo chiều dọc
hết
em không nhớ lắm
ờ ờ
cứ thử
nó ra for-loop như thế này hãy tôi nó
dậy mấy ông theo cậu Wechat 03 thôi
sẽ lấy bồ nó lấy bồ bản chất là bây giờ
mình cần một cái pho mày điền thông tin
nhanh thì u giờ đi Ở đây là đu dây đi
đây là
Ừ để xem nhé người đang ở đây
Ừ tôi đăng lên hàng rào ozid ở đây có
thể tự amin đang thì lấy luôn ăn
vì bản thân mình
a Company ID
Ừ
dạo này bạn này Ở đây có một cái nhé đó
là muộn là chọn Company có sẵn hay là
cho người dùng tự điền Company mới
ở cái đoạn này tôi sẽ để nó là Kiều
dùng Điền theo kiểu salad hay Nhưng mà
nếu mà không có thì
anh không có thì mình nhập vào à
dịch vụ cho người dùng tự nhập kiểu
Schannel được không chị xem nhé
sẽ tạo thêm một cái mới rất là xịn ta
khoảng Trung ai được đó nhé Ở đây nó vẫn
đề xuất nhá vẫn đề xuất trong những cảnh
như thế này nhờ người dùng có thể nhập
thêm như thế này và nó sẽ thêm một cái
riêng cho người dùng những người dùng
nhập cái đoạn option này tôi sẽ dùng
Ajax hoặc dùng Con bé Ly gì đó không mua
loa rất hay Kiều Lấy toàn bộ comple ra
Điền sẵn hiển thị ra trong cái ốp chân
đấy nhưng người dùng vẫn thời điểm thêm
vào cái điện thêm à tạo mới cái Company
mày không hình dung
ở chóp Thái thồ tự nhiên rồi đúng không
tiền thì Company trước đi
ở đây là à
a-class Lạc Long Quân cho tôi không nhớ
về cái giao diện Phone
i bought a
emp3 school đi không nhớ song ca
a label
Ừ ừ kiểu các bạn đâu mà đúng không sẽ
phòng control đi
à à
cả Company Ở đây có
thì mình sẽ tải một cái ở đây là crash
này
mình đây sẽ có Company
bằng Company này
thế này
a free và ghét như thế này
Ừ đợi thì nhá Đợi thì đây có
đi chích và City rồi Ừ nhưng mình vẫn
phải điền thêm mới Company này
cho mình thêm mới Company này sau đó thì
mình à
và sau đó thì mình cậu à
em gửi tí nữa nhỉ sau đó thì khi mình à
ấn vào đây mình chọn Company thì nó sẽ
tự động điên hội đít chết và City hộ
mình tự động luôn
điều này thì tôi như thế để xem
có thêm loại này phủ công kiểu này thứ
ra tôi thấy hơi mất công cái đoạn làm
thủ công một loại như này rất nhiều cái
mình không hề có thông tin của cam ly
đánh mình các bạn lại phải luôn nói
chung là thường là cho luôn hết tất cả
đoạn này cũng được
cho người dùng có phải cái người dùng sẽ
không Điền mấy cái này
cho ví dụ nhé ví dụ ví dụ của tôi nhé đó
là tôi có trước mắt thì cho cuộc gọi
Fire
Ê mày tổng hợp file đi này
Ừ để tên Company của tôi này này Ngôn
ngữ này
ở địa điểm này địa điểm tôi đã ghi nó
cũng hơi bị theo chuẩn pho mát rồi nó
cách nhau bởi dấu phẩy rồi này nhìn này
thứ nhiều này nhiều quá thôi không tổng
hợp nha anh nhiều
khi gà tự nhiều này lại mình phải tổng
hợp ra nó cũng thể là những cái gì người
dùng cái sau sẽ sẽ làm nữa Ở đây đó chưa
tổng hợp kịp giờ đây và link này
Ê mày đang ở đây nó vẫn sẽ tạo thêm một
bài đăng
làm thế nào lấy ra được bài đăng nhanh
nhỉ Mình có chóp hay thổ đây cho thai
thổ đây mình sẽ
chống được
remote cũng không biết này parttime
không mấy cái này thì ra khá nhiều cái
mình không biết đấy bạn này phải luôn
Apple khá nhiều
đương nhiên là mình vẫn có thể là tôi
nghĩ là tôi thêm xong ấy tôi thêm bằng
cái file nhanh rồi nhá thì ở sẽ có một
người sẽ vào Cập nhật lại thông tin mấy
cái thằng này nhanh kẻo mình cần là
khi bé làm giả sử người dùng ví dụ điển
hình chính tôi bây giờ đang có sẵn cái
file Excel này đúng ạ tôi muốn import
toàn bộ thông tin này vào nhanh và và
tôi sẽ chỉ cần sửa lại những cái thông
những cái nó đọc hộ tôi cái file này trả
lại rồi Tôi sửa lại cái file nhanh là
được Nếu hình dung rồi mở file lên nha
Rồi tôi thấy có một vài thông tin thông
tin gì đó đây Đấy sau đó thì tôi sẽ
cho tôi sẽ quay lại phom của mình để mà
điền nốt một vài thông tin còn lại rồi
Ấn enter và em nó sẽ nhảy sang cái tiếp
theo Đến Một sữa chẳng lại đấy mày cũng
hình dung không tôi sẽ phải để sống cho
phép chống rất nhiều cái thông tin ở đây
rất nhiều thông tin nữa đấy
ờ ờ sau đó thì mình mình sẽ kiểu có về
sau tôi sẽ đăng mấy cái thông tin ở lên
thật nhé Đăng lên tôi đang lên internet
tôi sẽ dậy mày ông cách để mà đẩy code
internet sau đó thì mấy ông sẽ có thể
vào cùng tôi ngồi sửa lại tôi sẽ cấp
quyền cho một vài người đó tin tưởng để
người ấy vào gọi là tôi cũng không rành
nữa tôi ra để cập nhật hết toàn bộ nó
ngay mà Thì mới ông sẽ hỗ trợ tôi vụ đấy
xe tải thì mẹ ông sẽ có thể vào sửa đọc
từng cái file này xong rồi vào sửa lại
sửa lại thông tin có sự hướng
sau đó thì
thế là ok
ở cùng lắm là tôi duyệt lại phát nữa
thôi nghĩa là mấy ông có thể là amin của
tôi là Superman hả Tôi sẽ là người duyệt
quấy Nếu tôi tự là người tạo thì sao top
này sao Tết này có thể trạng thái nhiều
trạng thái mà đúng không chạm xài là là
Superman Đăng lập tức là được lên luôn
rồi nhãn con trạng thái của Amin đang
thì nó sẽ là phải chờ chuyện ấy như thế
để mà ăn Superman duyệt nó sẽ tương tự
giống như là
người dùng đăng thôi
Em không hiểu ý tôi không Nãy giờ có bốn
mấy ông nghe nhưng tôi nghĩ mình không
cầm máy rồi rồi Cái máy nó tôi vui à
Ừ nhưng mày Ông hiểu ý tưởng được không
Tôi có sẵn cái váy xèo đúng không cần
import vào rất nhiều cái này rất là
nhanh đúng chưa ạ Đây cái này bài toán
về nghiệp vụ Đây bài toán đùa hay bây
giờ nhiệm vụ này Đấy sau đó thì sẽ phải
tự tạo ra bài đăng cái thứ tự tạo
Company còn tự tạo da Feiya cơ tự tạo
phải được mình phải tải cái file về
này về đâu thế cái bấm mà cho người dùng
bấm vào nhảy sang trang web Phú Thọ mình
không cần lưu file trong trường hợp này
anh không
vì lý do tôi ở đây có linh một là Link ở
trên đó là đường dẫn một là đường dẫn
của trang web trang web và ở bên ngoài
hay là trực tiếp trang của mình
thì
mình sẽ đọc qua nếu mà giờ sự ra đường
dẫn là http kiểu ngay chỗ sĩ nhảy sang
bên ngoài không ạ Còn không thì sẽ là ở
trang web Minh
dạy mày ông ấy cách inbox này luôn à
Anh thường à méo lễ post nữa nè
đại khái nó sẽ trông như anh
ở trong nhà chọn đúng không
cô gái cho tôi inbox cái này bằng cái gì
mà Chọn iPad 2 và có gì để tạo thì Đầu
Tiên Bây giờ tôi sẽ phải xin phép nào
tôi phải sửa lại cái đã toàn bộ những
cái cột có được phép luôn ở đây nữa cả
từ bài đăng đã cả có phân li mình sẽ cho
nun khá nhiều cột dây nhà mình sẽ phải
bổ sung những cái đấy thì tốt Mình sẽ bổ
sung mình cái đấy à
về máy thì inbox đằng kia và à
giống như cái Trang nagell data-table
ghê đâu chạy xe của Vân ở
nhá mình sẽ là làm tình năng inbox đi
cái gì khác không
ừ ừ
nút nữa là nút chắc là mình sẽ có một
cái con
a form mới đẩy pha lên được đúng ạ Mình
sẽ là pho ở đây này mình sẽ có lát
một cái
- phút
nên là
là
gì nhỉ à
anh đi bằng C về đi
a boss
đây lắm đợi tôi tí nhé Tí nữa mình có
cái nút bấm vào
nào nhé thường Ai cho về phải tôi thường
hay là lôgic các bạn này nhá Tôi sẽ cho
cái cái này nó là ẩn đi này
Anh
Hải đừng này
mà tại sao lại làm hai ẩn bản chất là
cái đút này bấm vào nó sẽ nhảy vào đây
đúng rồi nó lại bồ bấm vào
I watched C FB
anh không biết về sau của inbox cái khác
không
ờ ờ
anh đi
à à
em có ai đi a fault Ý là anh nhảy đến
a c P
thế này
có bước Thần Thoại
về bản chất hài nó có cái giả có cái
class giả mỗi tầng được
ở Tân tình
vợ chồng giao diện mà sẽ trông như thế
này à
class 2 bên WeChat
em có mấy nhỉ
- non đ
có được chọn file chị nào chỉ được đó là
tôi nghe cái này chỉ cho phép
ờ ờ
ừ ừ
ở giải thế thôi bỏ qua đi access
anh sex về refined ngày
cho phép tiền file này thôi
chị có ngoan chưa
xấu ống thép
đi lễ cung Nhu công hội à
hội chứng khó chịu nghỉ nó bị lạc ý nhỉ
ở địa lý
thời gian rồi sửa diện nha à
xe lửa
Tại sao lại lòng mang đi nhỉ
này được mà đúng không ạ
ạ Nếu hỏi chọn cho vui không ạ Mình sẽ
cứ mỗi lần cái này một lần cái trên mình
sẽ kích hoạt một cái gì đó
chị sẽ có đi sẽ có lại sự gì
ở mỗi khi cả ngày có thay đổi
tôi có bằng cái này nhé Xin phép cô bằng
cái này
gì đó đây đúng không ạ thì bản chất là
mình sẽ cần lấy được cái file ạ cái file
mình lấy mình sẽ là bình thường
ừ ừ
CR7 có phải lên xe grab ở đây này
thì mình sẽ à
khi họ đến router là amin
thốt là post cho chắn rồi ta say mình là
gà Mình ở mình trở về đi Xuân trả về
thông báo thành công với các bạn
Ừ cái mình trở lên sẽ là file a A và đây
sẽ là
sơ đồ logic
Ừ chắc thế nó chưa thử Em cứ thử của ig
tôi nghĩa được
Em thử thì biết không ạ thử nghiệm copy
đã này là đây
à à
anh ở đây mình sẽ trở về thành công hay
thất bại gì đó mình sẽ
Ê thằng nhà thằng Thái có vô này có cái
để thông báo đấy thôi tôi cho mày không
xem nhé Nó sẽ dùng cái A
cài thêm à mình đỡ phải càng nhiều
hội chợ tết
ở chung Tít Temple đây 1 tỷ phytoxin đây
sẽ thông báo một cái gì đó trong khá đẹp
như thế này
lại kiểu ngày
ở kiểu như này mình nhìn tường minh cốt
của nó sẽ trong nhà
ờ ờ
thêm cái gì ở đây xem thêm à
cốc này sẽ chạy được nhé
à à
ừ ừ
a background color sẽ là
anh Cường là miếng phải đặt như này
thường Minh
vì có skin này
là gì nhỉ nó vô rồi cần gì nhỉ
em coi tình
em không biết anh cần gì vừa rồi luôn Ờ
Motion em ạ
à à
a a cái thằng này là tốt Ok
em copy cái này phải nhanh hơn à
khi tôi sắp xít này cách này
ở show 2
The Four Seasons
[âm nhạc]
phải à import nói nhỉ đúng không có cái
tôi nghĩ phải có một cái
3GS ở đây để mà import vào
Ừ
thôi nghỉ luôn
ừ ừ
luôn xem được nha Tại tra này
kia giá inbox chưa có mình sẽ lại inbox
sẽ bê này là mấy thứ là post này à
ai có inbox CSV
A và đây sẽ ra
áo cotton cái này nó hơi bị
nó hơi bị mạng tí
vợ chồng là tên lại như thế này cơ
Âm Nhạc Ừ Ừ đúng là tay nó chậm như này
thôi sẽ phải sửa lại cái đặt tên ở đây
em gái mình sẽ khi mà mà đẩy thành công
xong anh sẽ làm như thế
khi mở nó không ra Đương nhiên rồi chắc
chắn làm sao ra được thì xem vào đây bên
này Quốc này
em chọn lại file mới ông sẽ thấy
nhược điểm gì nhé trên ở đây là nó thay
đổi rẽ phải chọn file khác thì nó mới
được thế trận Phai khác mà anh xem
nhỉ xem nhé à
đâu không làm gì hơi quen hết rồi
Xin chào
vì vậy
cài đặt spa pro
ờ ờ đợi thì được chị ạ
Anh nhìn thấy huyết hạ mỡ trong live Ừ
ok ok ok
vi phạm sáng hay đĩa 280 quan tâm đã ẩn
ở đây này tỉnh Quan tâm lại thằng nó
dưới hai chữ đã này
ờ ờ
khi đó nó sẽ đẩy lên nó sẽ đầy một cái
file lên như thế này tuy nhiên mình đang
trả với Chán chả với cái gì cả Không ạ
và nói và trứng vì chẳng lại trả lời cái
gì nó chọn rơi vào sheet cần phải trả
cái gì đó Nó bây giờ rồi xít cái mình sẽ
thử Peter này một ngày mình không xem
nhé Tại trang này
chị sẽ không tồn tại sao đâu chỉ cần
chọn file khác được đó Mày không thấy
báo chí đâu vậy nó trả về một cái gì đó
không ạ à
bài hát tại cái nào thế ra đó thì mình
sẽ dùng xh ở bình thường sắc bản chất là
nó ở xh nhưng mà nó là kiểu dạng mà viết
nó trông nó tường minh hơn Thử thôi
anh ở đây tôi sẽ tạo một cái file phải
anh post để mà import cái xe nhà thằng
kia vào đúng ạ import cái hai sẽ bê này
vào thì bây giờ đổi tiền mày không phải
xem qua cách để tạo file Porsche sẽ
trong nha Ai tôi sẽ chạy đâu đây inbox
là post ngay
đây sẽ support của bọn nó inbox
ở lại Ok
mình sẽ tạo cái file này và nó sẽ làm ở
report này pha này đấy
Ừ mình bạn chất ở đây bản chất ở đây nó
sẽ có kiểu dạng như này
ờ ờ
đã
từng kết quả của nó sẽ biến thành đối
tượng kiểu như này
thế nhưng nhưng
ở đây lại là phù hợp cho cụ thể với một
thằng ngu đồ thị xã Thế còn của tôi thì
mấy ông hình dung lại cái file
3D wifi nhé cái file này bạn chất ở khi
Mỹ bóp vào thì mình vẫn sẽ phải tạo
Company và và nếu mà chưa có mình sẽ tạo
Company đúng ạ nghĩa là tôi sẽ xử lý
tưởng bạn ghi một là tôi tạo Company các
thứ chứ không phải chỉ có mỗi tạo mỗi
thằng ngu đồ theo tôi sẽ không làm cái
kiểu như này
À mà tôi sẽ import thì cậu ngay
ờ ờ
cho tôi thường là tôi thường là nó sẽ
như thế này đặt thông tin
Collection như thế này
Ừ Ừ Ừ để xem nhé
nhà thuốc bổ đôi
đợi thông tin từ đại từ tiền
được không Sao không
Ừ mình vẫn sẽ tạo Company Nếu không có
đây
à à
ừ ừ
hết đâu hết kinh rồi mình sẽ thêm
heading lâu nó với Canon Gold ấy bởi vì
mày ông Để ý kỹ thì cái vừa rồi thì nó
sẽ là
ở tại cột thứ nhất là cô thứ hai sẽ làm
gì mình đôi khi vì không cần nhớ điều
đấy mình sẽ theo từng cột từng cột như
này mình nhớ
ràng là tôi sẽ còn tạo lưu lại ở trong
mảng file nữa tôi mua đồ này nó hợp để
hiểu là chỉ để inbox mỗi học tốt mà Đây
không phải inbox mỗi thằng boss mà anh
có rất nhiều
khi nổi tiếng
không làm được tu à
Ừ thôi chỉ import bình thường đấy
if you are a nhớ Toure ngoại tôi mua đó
à
ảnh như này có sao đây sẽ đây này ở đó
ở đây sẽ có mạng của tôi đấy hai bạn
chắc không trả lời cái gì cả
thế này đi
của tôi trong bể không xem nhưng mà tôi
inbox
ở hải ngoại ta lại
bài hát về quê chưa dùng và cái này mình
bản chất ở đây mình sẽ có pass inbox
à à
thì mình sẽ gọi đến nó bằng cách là
thì mình sẽ gọi điện nói như này
ở Excel gọi đến đường Linh anh nhé
ở Excel này
Ừ thì đã đến
Xóa ngay đi
và cái kết
thế này sau đó thì inbox
anh
nói nhiêu
em yêu ngay import inbox
Ồ vậy à
quét ở đây chuyển file vào
ở trong đây này sẽ là
hơn ngày nghỉ đi quét thôi
ờ ờ
anh xem bài Phát à
a http request a
em gái
khi họ chuyên báo ok này à
anh gọi
đi rồi đấy cho mày không xem
vì nó không thấy sẽ lỗi Tại sao lỗi à
a file đại như này à đúng không Nhưng
chuyện lên lại truyền em đừng dẫn chứng
là chuyện ấy hẳn cái file ngồi đây mình
sẽ phải là ma Giáp thì truyền file rác
file upload
về
bản chất nó sẽ như thế này
chị sẽ có and clip như này à
nó data
đây Dolls fall
xe Honda data
anh không tên hài
có gì đấy
Em sợ ai đi này
a porta luôn cũng được không
động thay đổi thông tin
Vì sao anh một không phải là
một bát ít thôi Quyến
giật ở đây không được
Ừ thì đã tính à đợi thôn tí
form submit a form và lấy từ fagor xe
Home Center a
I find my name
cái này rồi
chính là về cái bình đang chọn này
a wifi số một nhé
em nói chuyện vào file đây mình sẽ đặt
tên là CB
khi họ đặt tên là phải cũng được nhưng
vẫn chưa Ở đây
Ừ kiểu gì hàm của mình đưa xếp về rồi
không quan trọng nữa
Anh chuyển tài này thì này là lại sao
cho người tình không có vấn đề
xoay dáng
cô chuyển lên Sài free Fire
Ừ nhỉ
được tất cả báo nói đi ừ
ừ ừ có nghĩa tôi dưới ở đây thử
Đó ra dữ liệu rồi đúng không em không
thấy ra dữ liệu rồi đấy Cái đầu tiên là
bởi vì mình chưa có hết pin
xe tải mẹ ông thấy không có hết pin như
này không một ngày em mình sẽ đổ hết pin
mà ở đây là heading rồi mình sẽ thêm was
heading ở đây này cái
ở ngoài như này
I Bet ả lại khi em sẽ thấy da nó sẽ hiểu
ra là với công ty hiệu xảy ra như này
lại bị chưa có cái à
Dù sao thì mình trở lại à
ý nghĩa tên công ty rồi đúng không ngôn
ngữ là ngôn ngữ gì đó mình mình phải tạo
rất nhiều ngôn ngữ nữa đấy thổ địa điểm
là gì Địa điểm ảnh sẽ địa điểm của cả
phải đăng lại và cả công ty lại nó ngon
linh linh này sẽ link file này Đấy Nói
chung ạ Đây mình phải sửa lại hết hạn
cài
bảng này cho nó luôn libel rất nhiều cột
ngoạn xin phép tôi tạo các file để mà
tham make a
ờ ờ
cho con luôn
ăn people luôn đi à
a notable ô
ý là như này wi-fi nhanh
i i
nữa
tôi sẽ sửa lại xin phép sửa lại tất cả
các bạn nhé sẽ có
I eat cô rồi đấy
chị sẽ có giả sử bài đăng trước đi
anh gọi tí nhé
là
là make me Lotion
định không có nhé tôi tạo rất nhiều phím
tắt đấy
cho tôi tại lúc nào thì ông xem lại mày
mấy buổi trưa à
Nên có ít không có này này à
anh em mới Ông thấy nó gợi ý xin về
không
Down cái này đâu Xóa đào được không biết
có lỗi gì thì sợ đau rồi không nói chung
không có gì để đào và mình không có
reverse không có không report trong
trường hợp này
à à
à À quên chưa chia sẻ lên để cho mấy ông
vào Mày không nhắc tôi nhớ hình ảnh thấy
quen đấy
Ờ Ờ chắc trường tạo tôi nếu mà rảnh thì
bảo anh cái link âm ít lắm
nhìn nó rõ nhìn qua màn hình này giờ tôi
chia nhỏ là nhìn hơi khó
ở đây tôi sẽ có
À thì ra tôi hết tấm cái mày sang làm
thế này nhờ tôi muốn xem cái chat của
mấy ông Chat liên tục sang chắc gì có dù
thấy toàn cái cư hôm mà tôi dậy nghiêm
túc này mày ông ấy cho phát chẳng biết
việc cho biết mấy ông đang lắng nghe
thấy không
Mình sẽ có remote này
tên cột lại thành ạ
ừ ừ
được
hạn trả góp
I mean em này sau đó thì này
là nó sẽ
phết nhỉ
tiếp theo mình sẽ có
Nếu có thì mình mới là anh không nhầm
đấy Nhầm chết đó
cho tôi mấy lần như thế rồi
thì mình mới làm cái gì đó lại nó như
thế Tôi thích như thế này Ờ It's part
time này
à à
đi massage
mình lại phải điều hướng quay trở lại
không hư thứ
Ừ mình đang hướng dẫn các bạn về api cứ
làm quen với Áo Giáp Thượng sứ cũng tiện
mà
ừ ừ
cho kushi này ở có nhiều công ty để đôla
chúng mày để kiếm tiền Hiệp à
Ừ cũng được hồi chậm
ờ ờ con gì nhỉ it span không status mấy
cái này không thì bỏ qua này slot slot
của mình bản chất là nó sẽ tự cho biết
được bắt buộc phải đi angelis
em gửi lên giáp rót thay thổi mình trans
rồi về sau mình sửa được đoạn lắp này
tôi nghĩ là nếu mà tôi tự điền tôi sẽ
không tự điền đâu cho nó chạy À đúng rồi
quên mất tôi sẽ hổ thư viện để mà tạo
sắc tự động hộ mình nữa nó smart-table
một cái khá hay tôi sẽ ốp thư viện đấy
vào trong thằng mốt này sẽ xong nó sẽ tự
động tạo flash cho tôi này
a snack nerds
hai kỹ chẳng có khi chẳng có
34A
sẽ tự động tại Smart hộ mình theo Cột
nào mình muốn là nó sẽ kiểu đánh số và
đây nó hợp phù hợp cho siu nữa tôi yêu
và nếu mà trường hợp mà trùng này em sẽ
tự động tăng lên 123 cho mình tránh
tránh chung
tình ca đấy thôi
khi người ta cốt cái đoạn này thì ra
mình cũng tự cốt được không hả khó nhưng
mà nói chung và người ta nghĩ hộ làm hộ
hết cho mình rồi thì mình chỉ gặp xin
đem về mà dùng thôi Nó ngoạn
Linh courtney thì nó chỉ chạy được khi
mà tôi còn đang nhậu Thằng ạ Peso mày
tắt cả hai còn nhớ cái link này nó vô
hiệu mà là sao ông không bán được đâu
bạn à Mình sẽ con bạc ông vẫn I này sao
bảo file đối ngoại tại mình sẽ có copy
thằng này nha à
cách xóa bớt ơi
Ừ mình đi sẽ có là Company này đó
mình sẽ cũng ko có AD 2
khi extract miệng không có rồi rất nhiều
cột cần mạng loanable S2
cho cái vụ này là ngoài thúc ông cái này
ngao ý tôi là không có kiểu dạng là ở
trong exel rồi không có còn T thì ông
vẫn phải làm tròn mình nhanh p thì ông
vẫn là
a City City nhờ có rồi bỏ qua
canxi canxi canxi chủ yếu ở Việt Nam nhỉ
mình tí thôi thì đánh hết Anh Việt Nam
được
ô mê công ty kia mới nhớ
anh không có bị ở nước ngoài ở đâu có 12
công ty nước ngoài thôi kệ không quan
trọng
ừ ừ
U16 ở cùng ngắm mà Mấy ông Báo cáo lại
công ty ở nước ngoài có sửa lại sau
không chủ yếu Việt Nam Zip Code Zip Code
à
a record
ý thức à là xịt Cốt nó cũng tại sao mình
ở Điền giúp có làm gì
vì vậy
I Phone
à à
logo kiếm được Zalo bây giờ
ừ ừ
language nữa cơ còn language đấy à Ai đi
qua đây đi đương nhiên từ parody Mình có
rồi chị ah người ăn mi này link này hay
thay sẽ là
anh 2 triệu inch thì tội phải cấu hình
cả hai i5 cho nó là kiểu và bài gì đi
chứ gì đó bạn down
a language ngôn ngữ không có cái không
cần lại khá mình cần Trước mắt mình cần
2 bảng này có thể luôn đấy bố ạ
em sợ chạy
xin lỗi
em không có cột này tồn tại
Ừ ừ đúng rồi quên mất tôi mất nếu mà
chạy kiểu như này thì phải chạy dứt điểm
mình đây nó mới kết thúc nên mình phải
vẫn phải lấy cái cột này như thế này đổi
tên cột ok ok
ở đó học
Ừ vợ tôi sẽ
bộ phim bé phải
em sẽ thấy da nam boss bây giờ tất cả
đều cho new label nó tiện để mình à
inbox dữ liệu và
cận như Hải đúng không ạ sẽ trông kiểu ở
công ty xong rồi ta thứ anh có
ở đây mình sẽ có là công ty
ý là Company name bằng away I
ở công ty đó ngoại ngay chưa nó nó không
cần này Cho dù cái này có điểm rất là
hay của cái thư viện này đó là ông nhập
vào là cứng Việt có dấu đúng không ạ Có
dấu cách nó vẫn sẽ biến dạng kiểu kiểu
dạng thuốc lắc nó sẽ biến chuyển gạch
dưới nhưng cho ông Thư cắt thì biến Anh
cảnh dưới xong rồi tỏa Xóa toàn bộ thì
em có dấu gì chăng nữa nó sẽ biến thành
không dấu nhé Rất là ổn nhưng mà nếu như
có nhiều lúc trường hợp và ông vẫn muốn
giữ nguyên cấu trúc của trên này thì ông
chỉ cần ạ ạ thêm cái là no format của
headrow ông bỏ cái new format đi là được
đây đây for Custom mình nó sẽ hoa cà
iPhone 5 như này thì sẽ là lâu format
đấy còn không thì nó sẽ có mắt rồi cho
mấy ông
Ngôn ngữ này dow này
bằng android
ngôn ngữ
thằng PV stone nó không hiểu cái gì
không Đây sắp được
location location là ah chính xác đây là
city bằng ạ Harris
tại à địa điểm A
A
Gọi địa điểm rồi Linh Linh
vé máy bay tại link
đó so bây giờ mình sẽ tạo đầu tiên mình
sẽ tạo 75 astrid
E
bằng à
nhà mình có thể là UC Ford tất cả biết
hoa cái
em chụp cái đầu của cái thằng language
à à
anh nổi chuỗi với thằng à City
ừ ừ
ở TP
không không cần tìm cho tôi viết viết
chuẩn cái lo web Rồi ví dụ pp gạch ngang
xong rồi à Hà Nội cũng được nghỉ à
kia tôi sẽ hiển thị cái tên công ty có
thừa thứ ở dưới nước ạ Địa điểm ở dưới
không phải chọn rồi đấy tiếp theo City
này
a
21 people
ha ha Tại sao xài không luôn này lửa
em
đổi sáng
có hơi size
cùng với nhau
sử lý nha Tôi đi Có đúng không Tôi nói
đi bồ này trên này nhưng chưa kịp đổi
đổi sự tên thôi Thăng Hoa
ờ ờ
Cho tôi xin phép tôi lại tạo cái phanh
Dương chứ chị cho ăn luôn này bồ thằng
kia
Ừ để mai ông mang cốt của tôi về mấy ông
còn sửa được
chạy Mason chạy được mà chứ không phải
tôi sửa trực tiếp hôm nay thứ bảy tôi
rồi em mình sẽ ra a pin
Company I
a Hunter có Ruma
bộ remote
á Quân Idol
ca nhạc trữ tình hợp lý đấy à
à à
Ừ nếu mà Company này à
bộ remote table này
em
thế sao
a song
à à
ạ
bây giờ tải lại
The Flash
Xem trực tiếp video sex ai đấy Ừ
nếu có
ô tô các bài đăng nhập
đã sửa tên file cho đỡ hiểu nhầm đi
mày sẽ có
ở những sẽ có remote Apple không cầm
điện này đúng không
Ê status sao top mặc định rồi nhớ có cái
này full rồi
không phải là không nhưng mà trong
trường hợp nếu là admin như này thì mình
có thể xa tốt cho nên thẳng luôn mình sẽ
mình sẽ tạo quan trọng mình sẽ tạo trước
đã sẽ tạo một cái năm cho nó cũng sẽ là
ami5
như này
ờ ờ sau đó thì là tốt sao tất năm
nó
mở mở mình là mất rồi nhỉ
khi chờ đợi tin nhắn đi nhé
à À đây đây MK nhà MK II
ở đó
ở
đây tôi sẽ đến ăn chất nó sẽ vào cái
file Thôi vào cái mục đi 5 này chị sẽ có
ô ô sin
public
và mình sẽ đặt tên cho nó là ồ
không này tiếp theo là
ờ ờ
pending và
Ừ xong nữa là
Anh An Ninh Tây Ninh và
I am in apply đ
anh lại sợ có amin pending bởi vì á á
Ừ
ông ấy là kiểu
diệt hộ tôi nữa giả sử tôi nhờ mấy ông
triệt hộ trừ nạn thì tôi chỉ vào tôi xem
lại máy à Không phải duyệt hộ mà làm với
ông thêm chỉ xưởng hộ tôi và nhưng mà
tôi vẫn phải vào duyệt kiểm tra xem nó
đúng hay không đã chú ý cho thẳng lên
làm hệ cho chuyên nghiệp chuẩn mặn tốt à
nhỡ đâu Mấy ông già phá rồi
tự mình ở Thu mình không ạ
Nhà cháu ạ đó là tốt thắng luôn à và ít
tên Liệt thì ra bỏ qua lắc đấy thì tôi
bảo rồi vừa tôi chèn thêm cái thư viện
Mắt thấy bồ rồi chưa
xem lại nha
Ừ thì chỉ cần à
có thêm yêu cái của nó xong sẽ như này
em yêu smartcable trong cái bài đăng nha
nó đúng là bài đăng lên này thì mình sẽ
yêu smart-table này sao đó
Ừ thì mình mình mặc định là
à à
anh không hiểu này luôn kệ xuộc là thay
thổ luôn đấy Chuẩn luật giống hết mình
không khác gì à Không ạ thì nó sẽ đâu
nhầm lỗi tôi không giống hệt lắm Chắc
thay thổ Nga nó sẽ tự động tạo sự lạ của
mình thử nhỉ
ô thưa tôi thử copy cái này thử nhé
ở đây do tôi tạo cái file test Nói chung
tết đấy
ừ ừ
Ừ thế ở bên này đi
em
mới sáng tạo đây test này
scattle này à
à à
em không có nêm gì cả
này chắc là mình sẽ
A gọi đến kẹo ngay
Ý là mình sẽ truyền một cái gì đó
hai nước là TP
ở lại à
a City Ha Noi ngọn bao nhiêu này hồ sen
được nha mình sẽ có có bị
cách sửa thẳng đây luôn là Tết này
cái bọn họ
khuya bồ hơn kẻ thằng à à gà đứt
mình mình luôn phải nhớ là mình truyền
vào những cái gì trọng này họ hợp lý hơn
ờ
về phía bộ pin sẽ có là
chị đã copy ngay từ thống có rồi có này
à à
anh xóa nhanh thoại đi được
Anh
nhận lỗi tội lỗi tôi đang cho chị mày
ông cách về phím tắt gọi nha nha như này
đúng không Nút home này
sau đó thì giữ phím ship Bôi đen để Men
để nguội
khi nuôi và một cái nhầm đậu xanh
Hà Nội Tôi nói tôi
giữ này
các bạn mình hôm mày à
có ship
khi nuôi một cái xóa đi đó
anh em Tại sao ngày không được bôi nhỉ
xe lửa
Vì sao Chúc ông đấy mà
hình như làm sao mắc này nó tự động điên
rồi sẽ bỏ qua không cần phia buồn lắm
lúc sự trẻ
mình sẽ là
bản chất của Rơi đi mình đây sẽ ra
có thằng đang đăng nhập
thì như lỗ yêu rồi không nhớ nhỉ chắc
mình bị lỗi ao ấy
đã test thử trong những xem nhé biết là
bây giờ còn bị lỗi không
I Found
à à
em đang luôn nhé ok Giả sử bây giờ mình
đăng nhập đi sự đăng nhập nha
anh
không cần yêu Âu
Ừ cái này ở Yên hộ mình thôi Nó là hết
tôi anh hộ mình không ạ
cho sự đăng nhập nhé
giờ sẽ trả lại đây này nó luôn này à
trước ở Tôi cần phải sửa lại cái thằng
đau bộ này nó nó phải thêm giống như có
vài bạn nhắc chứ không phải là
chứ không phải là ở đây effort rồi mày
nhá
Anh không dùng lori nữa mà ở đây đấy Alo
đi nè
anh ở đấy đăng ký rồi còn đây Vẫn thêm
vẫn là
À hôm trước Hình như vậy lỗi với thằng
áo này
à à
để đảm bảo quan này đi à
Ừ thôi tôi sẽ sẽ ngồi sửa lại cái áo này
tôi sẽ em chỉ sau hôm nay chắc không kịp
thời gian để mà muốn sửa cái vụ đấy
mình cứ tạm cho ozid là bằng 1 đi chắc
là có thằng ngu rồi đấy vì chẳng có xong
Ý Nhi đừng có này
Anh có thằng một mà dọn lại mình sẽ cho
tặng ozid 1A
ừ ừ
à à
sửa đây đoạn này như thế này Mà tôi sẽ
Ừ tôi sẽ bắt trực tiếp khi mà sửa hay
xóa sửa xóa và thêm mình sẽ thêm vào
kiểu mình Fshare nó bắt trường hợp khi
mà thêm vào chứ mình không Mình không
ghi thủ công ở trong cái trường hợp như
này để tôi thử ví dụ về ông nhá
Ừ dạo này bỏ qua này mà khi mà mình thêm
vào Fristi nhí này mình tra lại cái quần
này
à à Không để yêu còn đưa xuống ship rồi
mình tra ốc sên này
anh ạ
ở Bắc sự kiện là khi mà khi mà nó đang
thêm
Đi học sướng cho sđt
a di tinh di tinh rồi
vì vậy là quần nhá là quần nhé á
Em hãy event Event Ơ
em vẫn đợi tin nhắn vậy
anh Sơn
a
web nhạc à
anh không đi làm quen với việc là khi mà
ở trên mặt với tinh
anh đúng không Thì mình sẽ
thế này sẽ là đô la trappe đi là tên này
so với xong để copy này gọi user ID này
xong rồi bằng một ngay em mình sẽ thêm
lúc mà đang tạo đang đang tạo thì sẽ
thêm vào
ưu đãi
Anh và cả lúc cả lúc có thể lúc kiểu một
ông tách hẳn nợ Ozon Fshare như thế này
nhá nhiều resort này tôi thích hợp cho
mấy ông thấy ở thì thường là thường
thích hợp cho kiểu khuyết tật đã tạo
xong hai đã cập nhật xong thì làm gì đó
còn Khi mà mình đang mình đang thiệu
đang tại đang sôi tạo như này hoặc cả
đang update thì mình sẽ mình sẽ can
thiệp bằng cái user ID như này chẳng hạn
cho hợp lý kiểu như thế
đây sau đưa nhiều Tôi đang kiểu hot cốt
hẳn là một con cái đang ấy phải là Woa
xong rồi ai đi như thế này nó mới chuẩn
nhé như này nó mới hợp lý này nhưng
chẳng qua tôi đang ta không có thì tôi
cứ để tạo ra một Tôi sẽ để tạm ở đây mẫu
nhà cho mấy ông nhá á
Ừ để hôm sau làm được cái bộ áo đã vô
tình tiếp đấy mình sẽ trong ngay
Anh ta lại nó
ở công ty ID Đúng rồi bây giờ nó mới
chuẩn này kìa đây ở đây mình cần làm
Company 2
à mình mình có Company rồi
à À không mình chơi và có mấy gì nhỉ
Mình chưa Company mà mình chỉ Company
name thôi
mình từ Company name lại mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ tạo company
a
Company nhá
bằng Company này
thế
này mình sẽ class II
đi à
này có City đấy cắn chui
sẽ là
khi nem là finals đông ạ ạ
à à
a City mình sẽ có City và
anh ở đây mình sẽ có canxi
có lương tri của mình cũng mà mình sẽ
mặc định là Việt Nam đi
đi theo công chính tôi ế thường sẽ là ổn
định sẽ là cậu mã mã của mã của công ty
được à mã của Canxi là kiểu vn do ngồi
dụng là us là hai vân Nhưng mà nhưng mà
ở đây tôi nghĩa để cậu ngay nó kiểu Việt
Nam đấy à
Ừ
để tiếng Anh ở được à
ừ ừ
Ừ để tiếng Anh nhé
Anh bảo kiểu này đi
chắc không sao đâu
ạ sau đó ở đây mình sẽ có là à
nay sẽ không ai đi à
Ừ nhưng mà ở đây có khái niệm đó là giả
sử là tên công ty tồn tại rồi thì sao
thế nên là đây mình sẽ là bớt
eclipta là chuẩn nhất mình sẽ kiểm tra
xem đã tồn tại công ty này chưa lại đi
đúng này
cái ông ông sẽ ông ông sẽ
em kiểm tra là nêm lên tồn tại không Nếu
mà chưa thì ông sẽ tạo với toàn bộ thông
tin này còn không thì ông ông trả về
thôi nó
Cho
tôi xin phép copy cái này
ở
tại sang bến test hết
là Company name sẽ là nó tạo ra hết đi
Ra hết cái này đi
anh đã bị cướp đi
Chị
Linh à a b c a
xong đây à
khi chạy phần ơi
khi nêm
à à mẹ chưa khai báo trong nhà
a cho Company này mình lại chưa có Cái
bộ nó lại phân tích cực thời gian đầu
đúng là phải khai báo cái này nhiều về
sau chỉ cần khai báo một lần nữa mà sao
mình cứ thế mà dùng thì tôi thấy nó tiện
không nổi bất tiện lắm thì còn nêm này
mình có City nè gà cần phải điên này
nhiều đâu ngọn hơn vất vả 1 tý gà có
cách đấy Đó là mấy ông có nhiều mẹo để
mà copy mấy cái này ra nhanh mà
à à
em copy sex thật có lông mày
cái nào nhỉ Anh nhớ là có tôi Hồi trưa
tôi nhớ có cho mà cậu lấy ra được toàn
bộ có lùng anh của bạn nó đó ở đây đây
tôi sẽ chỉ Email nào Giao
ghét có luôn nêm
à à
A Gọi đề companies
à à ê ê
có ai đi không này Này Cái Chết City
thật không nghe xong
nó dễ dễ mà đúng không ạ
anh có thể điền được những cái kia cho
nó như cái con điên đúng không ăn này đi
đâu có rất nhiều với hàm và rất nhiều
kiến thức cho người mà ông ngồi mò luôn
có lừa đấy chứ
Ừ thế được rồi đấy ngon rồi đây đó mình
sẽ đã có bài đăng này có Company đa cấp
này không ạ tả lại sang thì sẽ không tạo
thêm
anh không tạo thêm công ty vì công ty
chúng tôi rồi ông ạ nhưng mà bài đăng sẽ
tặng thêm vì mình không hề kiểm tra
chung và mấy ông thấy cái Smart tay bồ
này flash này ngon không chị nào Alo alo
alo gái rồi Mày ngon đúng không snack nó
sẽ tự động tạo hộ cho bé ông ạ Cái
Tôi nhớ thực ra vẫn còn nốt cái cuối
thả nốt thêm hai cái nữa là language tất
cả file vẫn chưa được tạo Tôi sẽ tạo
luôn bị sẽ có language không ạ Down à
nó tôi nhớ nó muốn nick chồng chưa nhỉ à
cái mình phải để uốn nick cái nêm không
thấy nói chung nhà ấy tự amin mình nhập
chắc chắn trùng Bây giờ đâu thì để đó
chắc cũng giống như cái kiểu ngay
là mình
mình sẽ là
the first of great những đúng kiểu nhà
đi lên nha
Ừ để chắc chắn nó sẽ không được cái
chung mình sẽ lăng với nhá xong
a tiếp theo nữa đâu nhưng mà Mỹ phải
fillable nó rồi ông ạ
cho sự bắt chước ở fillable nó
à à
cho nên
bình tĩnh bình tĩnh language này của tôi
nó hơi bị sai đối với trong cái file này
nó cuối của tôi có dấu cách cơ A ngâm
rượu cách của dấu phẩy cơ nghĩa nó sẽ ra
cách nhau bởi á cách đẩy cái thứ thứ
đúng hạn thì ở đây cái language bạn chất
là nó xuống nhiều
anh ở đây trông nó phải số ít truyền ở
đây nó là chỗ ấy bản chất là cho thai
thổ đây có dấu cách dấu phẩy không Sao
lạ nhưng mà khi nhập vào đây không được
có dấu cách dấu phẩy cũng như thế bạn
chắc là nó sẽ xuống nhiều đúng không ạ
thì Down ở đây tôi sẽ là đội nó thành
lang có ích như này là xpro cả nhà nó sẽ
cắt nhau bởi gấu cách sửa dấu phẩy như
này Đấy sau đó thì tôi sẽ chạy vòng lọc
Để fuik như này
with nào đó
à à
Ừ nếu chạy thử cho mấy ông xem đã nha
Tạm tắt thằng Boss này đi tắt hay là
ngày điện nha
thêm bao nhiêu ngôn ngữ nhé không báo
lỗi gì cả
mô tả loại này thêm một TP ngon chưa
Bây giờ tôi tải lại phát nữa này đúng
không
trả lại nó vẫn chỉn vẫn chỉ có mỗi phe
thôi giờ Bây giờ thì gửi tôi phải là tôi
cách này ra vây chắc mọi tả lại này đó
sẽ ra thôi không theo dõi cách thì các
chị nó alo alo nghệ sĩ nào ngon nghe đây
trong trường hợp người dùng nhập chuẩn
Đấy là tôi nghiệp chuẩn người khác mà
kiểu tự nhiên cọc thưa do cách 2 trên
dịch đó thì nó sai rồi lúc lấy chịu lúc
đấy phải sửa đây kiểu khác
thì mình sẽ phải dùng hàm chim rồi mà
cắt khoảng trắng và Vân Đấy và mình cắt
nhau bởi dấu phẩy để cho chắc thì tôi
thể làm cho đấy nghe giờ sẽ chim kiểu
nhà cắt nhau chi mà đây là chim này nhá
079 kia đó nhé mày không được nhỉ Dịch
đấy thì nó sẽ chuyên mà nó sẽ cắt mỏ
khoảng trắng ở trong chuỗi không không
phải cắt dùng sung Xóa mọi còn trắng
không đúng lắm mà Cái này sẽ cắt toàn bộ
khoảng trắng ở đầu và cuối của chuỗi sẽ
ra ổn tiếp theo nữa là mình sẽ có bảng
file
khi bạn phanh thì à Urê đi có post ID
pass ID chính ra Hà không ạ link này và
xoay thai thì ở đây tôi đang định là 2
nó là file mình sẽ tạo cái à
file Hye mi 5A Ừ ngoan ạ
là D ạ là hoa lạ và
phải có những pha gì nhỉ
sẽ copy cái này
à à
Em có phải đây
mua đồ rồi mua đồ đang đâu đấy à glad I
ở
đây mình sẽ có là Anh Linh này posted
em có lại đi sẽ chính là tốt cho đến nay
đi Thế thằng này
Cho tôi mở lại nha Cái
thì mình sẽ tạo có ở đây bằng ngay Cậu
bắt đi tiếp theo đó là mình có
ông đinh nhọn Linh chính là Linh ở trên
chị Linh ở trên tiếp theo nữa mình có 2
có
ai mặc định mặc định tôi nhớ là có mặc
định rồi mặc định nó là một thì Vậy là
chưa mặc định tự điện được không Sao mà
hay thay Năm
em đã nghi
Ừ để cho hai thằng một luôn à Sao lại
sao lại
là ok truyền vào tự nhiên là mình sẽ
phải tạo và
về phía bố nó rồi
ở
lại phát nữa xem ảnh không
à à
tại sao cái của tôi ở giữa không được
nghỉ
nào nghỉ à
toàn ấn nhầm nút
Ừ cái thích đăng ký gì nghe nước rồi
ở bàn phím bàn phím này cho quay nó làm
thông cảm em cả
hơi cầu kỳ nếu mà ba cái có khi xóa
phông tay nhanh hơn nữa tới chị mấy ông
phím tắt thôi à
ở đó
anh chạy tối tin chạy được anh em thế
nào
xin lỗi với thằng này đều Nhật à Có
không tồn tại ở trong bảng bảng file
bằng file không hề có
à
ở Hà Nội của New Zealand đi nữa quên
quên quên quên quên mình sẽ phải sửa đây
rồi đi Khi mà
à à
A gồm viết xong thường là mình sẽ vứt
sau mấy cái thằng khai bảo như thế này
nhé a
di tinh này cũng lau ngay Rơi đi tắm một
đi tạo một đi
Ừ ok rồi
em thử xem nha
I find có rồi nè Linh ABC
a language vẫn thế đối ngoại đó công ty
vẫn thế và bài đăng thì tạm được nhiều
rồi Nãy giờ tại xanh chục lần rồi mình
cứ tặng Xóa hết toàn bộ bài đăng đi Này
bây giờ mới anh Chính thức làm thật này
ở Hà Nội song đào khoai nữa
ý
thức a mình nên tạo khoảng ngoại thì cậu
ràng buộc là cho phép xóa chứ không phải
là kiểu là
khỏi lại như thế này
Khi ra về sau mình có cho xóa bay đang
nghỉ
Ừ chắc là có nếu bài bị report đi trắng
là mình phải kịch Tết ở kia không thì
thực chất thôi nó không hẳn đã xóa hạn
Ok Ok Ok Thế cơ tạm xóa Phai đã nó phải
lại phải ráng mà sổ đỏ sau bài này
Ờ
Ờ bây giờ đến giờ làm thật rồi nhỉ anh
chạy phát ra luôn này gì đâu chạy ra
luôn này copy tất cả đúng này nhá
sang Porsche inbox
khi sex
Ừ Anh nghe này
bộ đèn pha luôn à
à à
ờ ờ
Tại sao Lỗi À đúng rồi mấy ông để kỹ cái
lỗ đây mày ông sẽ không hiểu tại sao bị
lỗi này nếu mà trong thường mà mày không
bị lỗi như này thì mấy ông cần à trai
cát Nó đã cho ai cát ngày để mà xem thực
sự tại sao lỗi
copy cái này vào đây này sau đó thì D ở
đây
Anh để xe mà nó bảo nó không tìm thấy
cái công ty ở một cái chỗ nào đấy tự cho
mình không xem cái
à À không không không Cái này tôi bị
nhầm đấy Cái đáng lẽ phải là vô ích
Ừ kệ Android tưởng thằng ngay sau đó
mình mới đổ dữ liệu vào trong từng thẳng
em nói chuẩn đập thủy đợi tí đi
à à
xin lỗi
vì một nền cái lót bị lùn
anh gửi tin nhắn tới tí nhé
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
company's Tại sao có 1
a Company chó nhà
Ừ đấy thì tôi vừa bảo đấy nếu là trong
trường hợp mà mày không không biết nhà
thì mày ông cái chai Cáp như thế tôi nhé
á anh em copy toàn bộ đó ngay vào này
tôi tạo phím tắt của chai cáp ở trong nó
mới nhảy ra các được nhanh nhanh nhé
xong rồi in ra thằng nào cũng vấn đề nha
nếu không xem được
ngôn ngữ pp này đường link này cho chị
xem thử tại sao lại bị cháu đi nhờ thằng
ở đây đây đây một hòn bi trống không ạ
Cả
ngày nhớ là này thôi không xin được tên
của company
Ừ ok không xem được tên Company không xa
Nếu thế thì à
ừ ừ
anh như thế thì companyid ở đây cái bài
đăng có companyid dùng nha Đúng rồi Thế
đi companyid đấy cũng phải được phép
luôn thì nó mới được mà mới được gặp lại
ở đây ok
lại luôn cả máy cũ này đi
myrosin vãi
dù rằng rất là nhiều đấy sau mấy ông sẽ
phải cân nhắc lại sửa lại mái chuyện khó
hiểu
Company
ID l khuyên mà Mấy ông này đúng không
mày ông đang làm đồ án mày có ngồi sửa
lại cũng nhiều nha mày Ông cẩn thận nhé
để luôn đấy Bồ được cái cột nào nung nhé
á
Ừ mình đây sẽ là
à
mình mình vẫn phải lấy lại cái cũ là
Bích sai đấy
Ê bà đây mình sẽ luôn Apple
ở trên
Ừ ok này
bình thường mà mày Ông thấy vừa rồi in
xuất lỗi lỗi như thế đúng không ạ thì
mày ông nghĩ rằng là thôi chết rồi mình
đi suốt tầm chục bạn nghĩ Tự nhiên có
một thằng bạn đi bị lỗi thì bây giờ mình
biết được bạn ghi đấy bạn như nào thì
mình xóa bạn nghĩ khác đi Vân phải xóa
những bạn khác nữa không thằng level in
inbox inbox Excel là này nó điện rất là
hay bảo là
đó là nó sẽ cho vào một trang xuất chân
trong sân thôi gà khi mà có vấn đề gì đó
thì nó sẽ chỉ cần robot mà quay ngược
lại cái sừng đấy đã khôi phục lại toàn
bộ dữ liệu nhưng mà chưa từng chưa từng
xử lý cái gì cả đấy là
cái này rất hay này ra phù hợp việc mình
phải chắc chắn Đúng rồi hết đã tự như
mình vẫn có thể bỏ qua mình mình có thể
bỏ qua được cái vụ đấy mình vẫn sẽ in
xuất nhận hàng hợp lại thôi cũng được
nhưng mà Đúng rồi sau này mình thể gộp
Mason nhưng mà nhưng mà lỡ cô dạy yêu
mày ông à Đang muốn dạy cho mày ông quen
với việc kẹo khi mà đẩy lên phó chừng
đẩy lên hẳn thực tế rồi thì ông phải sửa
thủ công từng cái từng cái như thế đương
nhiên là thực em nãy giờ tôi có thể
không cần lấy vội tôi vẫn thể robux quay
trở lại nó Vân để mà bản chất là file
này tôi đã có mít lên đâu Đây là thành
nha tôi vẫn thể sửa pha Này Con Không
sao cả nhưng tôi đang dạy mấy ông này
ông ấy không hiểu qua làm quen với việc
về sau vấn đề thì mình phải làm đúng
thiểu phải làm lằng nhằng Mai ra sân
ngay thôi
bought này companyid hệ để cháu rồi ông
ạ
cho mẹ xong
ở đây mình sẽ là
Ừ không sao xa a Company name ở đây là
gà trống anh ra là
a m t
a company
khi nêm gà nghĩa là chồng đấy một là
trống là kiểu nó là chuỗi trống
dự án đầu tiên nếu không chồng đã thì sẽ
điều này em thì company
mẹ là một là lấy
Ừ đấy được comedy ID hai lá cho nó băng
này một là ông làm thì tưởng như này hay
là ông có thể làm kiểu như này
anh sẽ dạy cho mày ông hai cách
Ê mấy ông ạ nếu mà ông gọi chuyển ngay
nó sẽ bị báo lỗi để mặt thằng này có thể
không được Tại đúng không ạ Hãy new nó
không còn tại vì đó thì ông sẽ cho nó
trọng ấp Sino ngay
là thằng này có thể tồn tại không chọn ạ
nhé ai Chắc chị chọn Tránh chỗ luôn thôi
Ừ ừ thợ làm mấy cái kia đi
Ừ rồi chúng có vẻ cũng ổn Đấy trả lại
phân nữa nha ngày chứ đàn ăn rồi
Ừ nhỉ nhỉ
khi
đó tuổi thêm được rất nhiều Đông ạ Mấy
chị a mẫu rồi nhưng mà không thấy cũng
ngon mà ngon đó thêm được cả language
này
Ừ nó
à Nhưng cái này có nhược điểm đó là như
tôi đã bảo tự nhiên nóng quý ở đây có
cái lo rất nhiều chẳng buồn cười đấy
tiếp theo là giờ tất cả công ty cơ sở
hữu anh vẫn chỉ ra mẫu đầm Ôi nhá Đang
mẫu để mô cũng như là mình sẽ phải làm
thêm vài cái nữa mà hôm nay nói qua được
về khá nhiều cái thư viện cũng như là
cách xử lý bài toán mấy ông thấy ạ có
rất nhiều cách xử lý bài toán không ạ
tôi chỉ có cả từ cơ bản đến nâng cao chỉ
thêm cho mấy ông cách test các thứ thứ
thứ nữa api nói qua api Thật ra rất khó
để mày hiểu tôi đang chỉ dậy từ từng
từng từng bước từng bước nhỏ này ông
hình dung qua thôi cho hôm nay chính
thức không phải kiến thức cơ bản giống
như mấy ông nghĩ tiêu đề có hệ CRD xem
thử Xóa Nhưng mà thực ra hôm nay chị làm
mỗi mỗi thêm rồi chứ chẳng có sửa xóa
thì đây cả cũng chưa xem thì cả đúng
không ạ phức tạp rồi ông ạ Ê mày kiến
thức đấy là kiến thức kiểu Dạ nhà khi bà
làm ra Idol chuyên nghiệp rồi sẽ quen
dần tất cả những cái mấy cái này không
thấy à Khá phức tạp không ạ
Ừ Ok chắc bữa hôm nay tạm thời Thế đã
tạm cũng chưa trả
anh cũng À
cũng chưa trả lời câu hỏi của mấy bữa
trước cũng như là chưa tâm sự được tra
để buổi hôm sau tôi sẽ trả lời câu hỏi
mấy mấy ông Hôm nay thấy của vấn đề gì
hiểu như bình luận về mà tôi trả lời câu
hỏi tôi đã xem lại buổi hôm nay ở các
thứ thứ nha
Thôi trả lời
anh Bởi vì à tôi dậy mấy ông Nếu mà mày
ông không hỏi thì thôi cứ dậy đều đều
đều toàn bộ kiến thức khó mấy ông sẽ bị
quá tải mà ông cần nên hỏi
sao
Ừ thì đấy nghĩa bắt buộc cả chúng ta
phải thêm chuẩn không ạ Đấy Chứ còn việc
mình thêm Lang kiểu này thì ra nó không
hẳn thuận lắm nhưng mà tôi bảo rồi thì
cái file file file mình nhập và đương
nhiên bắt buộc phải file dữ liệu chuẩn
rồi mình không Mình phải ra đấy à mình
ra đến đoạn mạng khá phức tạp mà đúng
không
Mình tự làm khó bản thân mình thôi à Nói
cho bạn này bắt bộ mình làm chuẩn thôi
khi có bội mày nó tự nhiên đến lúc nghỉ
tự nhiên 56 ông vào đây
nữa Ôm Nhưng mà dù sao thì kết hôn nghe
60 ông nào ạ Mày bị điên à
ah-64 mấy ông chết rồi đúng không
ai đời tự nhiên vào đủ xô vào làm gì làm
đi
lễ hội đền chỉ Hi Chào mấy ông nhé Có gì
buổi Bạn có bất kỳ cái Thăng gì thì buổi
cứ như bình luận để mà tôi tổng hợp lại
có hỏi để mà trả lời nhá Có thể là mấy
ông thắc mắc và giải giải được rồi nhưng
mà cũng chưa chắc đúng vào cả muốn tôi
dạy để mà góp is tất cả các bạn được mà
nó ngon
HD72
Chắc chắn là bị ông mở nhiều Tab rồi tôi
không tin đâu rồi thế nhá chả mẹo
[âm nhạc]